Let's look at some examples of UIs for
tablet's that are less than optimal and
see where they break down.
We'll use the factors we discussed
as a rubric for grading each UI.
This first example shows
a list of messages or updates,
perhaps it's some kind of social app.
It's essentially a list with
full width text and images.
Let's see how it does against our
rubric for what we're optimizing for.
Now firstly, I don't think this design
offers a balanced use of space.
The left alignment can leave lots of
empty space and it feels a bit lopsided.
Secondly, any time you have full width
text, this isn't optimizing for reading
comfort as you're likely to exceed the
45 to 75 character line lengths we want.
Lastly, I'd say that this design risks
blowing images up to fill this width,
sacrificing quality.
This next example is something
like a detail screen,
with a full width image with
an awkward aspect ratio.
Looks like it might have a fixed height,
but a fill width off the screen.
Then it has some text
content top left aligned.
Looking at our optimization goals,
odds say that this design
isn't very balanced.
All of the content is concentrated
here on the top left.
This design also doesn't seem
to respect image quality.
Displaying a small sliver like
this is likely to only convey
a portion of the whole image.
Lastly, I'd say that there might be a
missed opportunity to maintain context.
This looks like a sparse detail screen.
It might have made more sense to show
this info in a larger context, say,
in its own panel or dialogue.
Our last example tablet screen
shows some kind of image feed.
Here the images flow
horizontally from left to right.
Again, looking at our rubric,
I'd say that this design doesn't
make balanced use of space.
We have dense content here on the left
and sparse areas here on the right.
This design also doesn't optimize for
image quality.
It's not that the layout is likely to
blow up images, it's more of a missed
opportunity to display them
more richly or interestingly.
This design appears to use a fixed
size for each image, which is a shame.
Why not make better use
of the space available?
Lastly, I've marked it down for
overall aesthetic.
I'd say that this kind of jagged look,
like this, is somewhat awkward.
While these examples might seem
contrived, they're representative
of how many apps out there today
aren't thinking adaptively.
With some simple tweaks,
you can vastly improve how your app
might appear on larger devices.